it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the
nspca and she brought along someone who
needs a safe and good home
how you doing amy hi i'm doing great
thank you
so um this is sam i mean this guy is so
sweet and so cute sam is a senior
sharpay mix
um we kind of decked him out in
halloween colors because he's he's black
a dog with
his little orange bandana at nevada's
cca banner but he's
a really truly sweet dog we actually
told him from another rescue that needed
our help and his his time was coming up
so we brought him in and he's been
nothing but sweet um he'd be great in a
home that just
can give him easy walks around the
neighborhood to the park he doesn't need
anything too crazy because he's a little
bit older
um he does have a little bit of
arthritis which is just natural with a
dog his age
like i said he's about 10. um but we
really want to find him a great home
because he
is so sweet and deserves it well you
know the fun thing about
what you guys do you still even now
you're allowing people to come visit the
dogs right
and see if they jive with the pets
absolutely by appointment obviously we
still have to kind of control
um you know we're standing by our you
know safety regulations with covid but
yeah people make appointments come in
and we want you to kind of
bond with the pet so we come in and we
answer as many questions as possible
while you do your meet and greet with
the animal just to make sure it's the
right fit
and you can even bring in if you have a
pet or pets already at home
you can bring them with you to see if
sam for instance
gets along with them yes if you have a
dog
um at home and certain dogs certain dogs
will tell you right away hey you know
this dog is a one dog only household but
other dogs um and sam correct me if i'm
wrong sam is okay with
um seems to be good with other dogs
we've done some assessments and
evaluations with them and he seems great
so we want you to bring your dog from
home so we can meet them and see how
they interact
and just to make sure there's not going
to be some you know hopefully no issues
at home
he seems like a sweetie amy thank you so
much
all right if you're interested in
adopting a pet you can go to
nevadaspca.org
or call that number 702-873-7722